we know from a neuroscience perspective
it takes about 66 days to create a solid
enough neural pattern that it'll go from
conscious effort and thinking about it
to a non conscious pattern that has the
beginnings of automaticity happening
without your involvement you're just
doing a limiting belief is like putting
the governor on the engine of a Ferrari
I think the movie The Matrix is the
perfect metaphor for the human
experience we have all pulled a web of
lies over our own eyes want to be happy
build a life not just the business
[Music]
every single day we're cutting it out
solo you and I believe in life
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believed life and learn how to use the
power of your mind to destroy your
negative limiting beliefs enjoy okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
get rid of the governor with Jordan
Belfort a limiting belief is like
putting the governor on the engine of a
Ferrari before I can go 240 miles an
hour it has 550 horsepower four valves
per cylinder twelve Cilla's but if
there's that governor not letting the
gas go for you ain't going on 55 yeah
that's what a limiting belief does it
stops you from charging forward when you
should and cause you to move back when
you shouldn't and we all have them they
create and they started getting inserted
in our heads with more yeah big you know
you all stop bowl on day one and then
came day two when our parents started
spoon feeding us limiting beliefs
sometimes you know they meant well they
just didn't know because you know one of
the things that I'm a big believer is if
we were not only given our owner's
manual my brains an immensely powerful
computer and this is you know known by
pretty much everybody in the self
development from the top people dr.
Richard Bandler I trained with a great
one my mentors and a brilliant guy and
the first thing he said to me is you
know you never got your owners manual
Jordan and because that you don't
realize that the world around you that
you take it is reality it's really not
it's subjective the reality I'm looking
at it's just subjective
I can't interpret things out I want I
can have the beliefs that that that that
empower me and I can shed the beliefs
that disempowering so the first thing I
do when I meet somebody I work when I
coach really wealthy people some stars
in Hollywood the first thing I do is go
through what they're limiting beliefs
are yeah and you're gonna route them out
and it's not difficult you gonna
you can't just route make it and replace
them with empowering beliefs we just
took typically the opposite belief right
now what I was doing at my brokerage
from interesting Lee you're not getting
back to that is each day at my firm I
give you read the book I gave two
meetings in the morning meeting and the
afternoon meeting yeah and in the
meetings I was actually running this
strategy I had them visualizing their
success I would talk about the lights
now the
average kid that came to work news about
as smart as a box of rocks
they were they'll let you know none of
the kids went to college okay they were
not the lucky sperm Club members
it wasn't the deep end of the gene pool
or anything like that at all yeah these
are the Forgotten these my people right
now they came to me they thought be
working with pizzerias and that first
thing I said to them was this the moment
you walk through this door everything in
the past falls off you sit behind this
desk you say the words I teach you you
become as powerful of the most powerful
CEO in America what am I good I'm
breaking a limiting belief great you get
that I didn't know you didn't know that
you didn't know I was just saying it's
like I got wild up myself and I saw
these kids I want to help them there and
I knew what they needed to hear because
they grew up in households where they
were told they were worthy of greatness
they weren't all they were had the
ability to be successful every human
being if I say I give seminars I give
two days seminars right and you can't
believe the dramatic changes in people
in just two days and it's not that I'm a
guru it's like I'm just a guy with a
unique set of skills that I followed
over 27 years of doing this and I know
there's these basic trigger mechanisms
in people and when you're giving then it
empowers them and then they go on from
they run and they go for it and they
realize what's in their cable things I
never thought they were capable of and
it's to see that that's what gets me
going in my life yeah
happened back then with the kids at
strong also if you want to have more
confident self love and motivation check
out my 254 series they're free the link
to join are in the description below the
only thing that stops you from getting
what you want in life is the [ __ ]
story you tell yourself there's a gap
between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish I just
have a value system that says it's not
about the money it's about building
something you believe in it's about
serving other people it's about work
ethic it's about showing up and working
and rule number two the last one before
our very special bonus step is develop
discipline with John as raft if you
think about the era that our parents
lived okay
Great Depression yeah right very very
hard to make money very very hard to
find resources very very hard to do
anything unless you're a professional so
our parents said to most of us if you
don't become a professional
you're gonna struggle you're gonna
struggle and suffer and even the
professional said okay so become a
professional and here's your ceiling of
what you have so we came conditioned to
be worried of scarcity in a world that
has no scarcity we became conditioned to
having certain beliefs about what's
possible or not possible so even now you
know as we as we you know we're sitting
here and we've got this you know amazing
election time crazy you know what I
think is everything about is you know
there are some people to believe that if
Donald Trump wins they're gonna make a
fortune and there's other people the
thing they're gonna lose everything and
I have a friend of mine who has got
about seventy million dollars in the
bank that believes that if Hillary gets
into office he's gonna lose millions
it's gonna be really tough and what
really is you know going on in people's
heads it's it's all of their references
their beliefs and their perceptions that
are locked away in the implicit part of
their brain that is driving those
thoughts and even the behaviors they may
not even be aware of it they're not even
aware of it yeah they can be but there
may not be and so what we really have to
go back to to focus on is it really
makes no difference who becomes
president or who doesn't if you have the
belief that regardless of what happens
in your external world you can navigate
towards the success that you want that's
a belief and beliefs are the lens by
which we actually see the world and by
which we behave and so if you want to
change your results don't focus on
changing your behaviors change your
focus on the beliefs that drive your
behaviors right yeah and so the next
question though is real great where on
what kind of beliefs do I have right
well we have two types of beliefs and
this is this is where it can get a
little bit you know a heady and that is
you know when you start talking about my
brain it's an organ it's like your heart
is an organ you can speed up your heart
you can slow down your heart you can you
know speed up the brainwaves in your
brain you can slow them down you can
tune in you can tune out yeah we haven't
been given the user's manual for the
most powerful teachers that we're aware
of
right and so the great news you know I
know you being an athlete and a
successful businessman you have
disciplined you cannot achieve results
without some kind of disciplinary and so
we know that there's some fundamental
truths to achieving success and every
successful person will tell you you know
and Jim Rohn is I know you you love Jim
right so you either play pay the price
of discipline you pay the price of
regret discipline weighs ounces or Greta
weighs tons but the the thing is can you
teach discipline the answer is yes how
you have to have a willing participant
and if the participants reason why is
big enough if they know I want to
achieve X and the reason why the motive
for their action motivation the motive
for their action is a reason beyond just
themselves chances are they will do more
to achieve that success than if it was
just left up to their own but there are
some people that are born you know with
incredible Drive they just have this
insatiable drive and they'll just I'll
do whatever it takes for the things that
I want and there's other people that
want things but they just don't have
this insatiable drive and this is where
you know I as much as I hate at school I
love to use schools in an algae there in
the game of life with its health wealth
relationships career business
spirituality fun experiences you have to
decide what level the game go on to play
it is it the great school level the
kindergarten level the high school level
the university level the pro level
because each one of those levels
requires a totally different mindset and
totally different skill set they're
building blocks on each other but if you
are extremely talented but you're not
prepared to practice and rehearse and
drill and fall and fail forward to the
next attempt you will never make it as a
pro you will never make as a probe isn't
this person you'll never make it as a
pro husband or wife or athlete or
musician you just never will so just get
used to that if you're not prepared to
pay the price if you are prepared to pay
the price and you have the aptitude and
the talent now we're talk about there's
some real potential here and what we
don't know is you know what's in your
heart
what is the fire that stirs you that
that you wake up say I will do this even
when I don't feel like it I will do
whatever it takes to overcome my
temptation for mediocracy my temptation
for excuses my temptation for reasons
and circumstances to hold me back I
won't allow those to be in my way hmm
and if you have that within you you'll
achieve whatever you choose and so the
question you asked before is how do you
develop that start small yeah start
small so if you don't have discipline
show to you show yourself that you can
give yourself one command and one
follow-through so you know what right
now I'm gonna get up I'm gonna do two
push-ups
right now not not like later now can you
give yourself a simple command one sit
up right now I'm gonna go get a glass of
water you start with something
ridiculous I learned many years a reduce
it to the ridiculous
hmm so for a ducek to the ridiculous and
I start that so can you do that great
will you cuz that's the difference right
there is that's the razor's edge can
will you will you yeah great when now
now yeah right so if you develop that
skill and specifically from a brain
plasticity and neuroplasticity
perspective as soon as you do that you
give yourself a command and you take the
action you have just created a neural
pattern you can give yourself a command
and take action now that may be just be
one time well what if you did that every
hour by putting a little bell on your
computer and every hour like if you were
if my computer is open I'd have every
hour it would say it's Volvo clock
it's one o clock and I take 60 seconds
just to be in control of my mind
67 don't care where how would you do it
stop take six breaths or you just get it
just get centered and my on track and my
off track am I doing something I
shouldn't be doing versus a high impact
activity that I need to be doing every
hour I've trained myself to just reset I
didn't always do that so I just started
with one a day right then - sure then
three then it was working so well I said
great let's do this every hour but more
importantly as soon as you
come the person who believes in
themselves you see every thing you do or
don't do leaves an imprint on your
self-worth and self-esteem scale and you
know it absolutely you know it every
time you have that cake or that cookie
right you do believe in yourself you
don't believe in yourself right yeah
every time you're you're voting with
every decision you're disqualifying with
every negative belief you're qualifying
with every posits a m-- with behaviors
so you start to get getting aware of a
my qualifying myself to move forward or
am i disqualifying myself do what I say
I want and what I do or don't do over
and over and over because thought
patterns become emotional patters become
behavioral patterns and our brains pick
up on our thought emotional behavioral
patterns and says hey you know what
you've done that one enough I'm just
gonna make that automatic for you so all
of a sudden you know if you're a person
has lots of positive thoughts but you
suck at taking action your brain says
let me make that a permanent pattern for
you so you don't have to think about
anymore but I'm also going to create
some neural tension and I'm gonna make
you pissed off at yourself now now
you're gonna start talking to yourself
about how you don't want to not take
action but you're still taking action
and this is where we have this conscious
non conscious ping-pong match going on
all the time Plex
yeah it's actually complex but it's
actually pretty easy too the first step
is to take one thing I'm gonna go back
to one thing yeah and say great let me
move one thing forward why because that
just changes the trajectory of the same
pattern repeating itself and as soon as
you interrupt a pattern and then you
repeatedly interrupt the pattern it's
like taking a detour and as soon as you
take a detour one day you're gonna like
okay that was that was okay but you
intended your tennessee's to want to go
back to what's comfortable but if you
take the detour two days six days seven
days we know from a neuroscience
perspective it takes about 66 days to
create a solid enough neural pattern
that it'll go from conscious effort and
thinking about it to a non conscious
pattern that
the beginnings of automaticity happening
without your involvement you're just
doing yeah and so for me what I do and
for myself is I whenever I want to
change something whether it's a habit
whether it's a thought or emotion or
behavior I say I'm gonna work on this
from 100 days not 30 days not 21 days
not 66 which is right around there I say
100 days and then I focus all of my eye
just on that one thing for 100 days so
you take one thing just one thing that
you know may be a little challenging 100
days a hundred days just 100 days so
let's say you want to drink more water
100 days a glass add a conscious effort
to one a day whatever you did before
you'll still do but one glass a day so
you know I started that with my
assistants I want to drink you know like
four of these a day you know like you
know 32 ounces whatever the case is and
so every we got a mug and it's on my
desk
every time I walk in and then I have
some support from ER saying hey remember
to drink your water
so just so the first you know 2 3 weeks
I feel like I'm gonna drown myself in so
much water but then it's like okay now
I'm used to it now I'm drinking as much
water as possible because the habit is
there and one of the rules that I love
to follows the habit is more important
than the intensity at first so don't
worry about the intensity right develop
the habit so can you take one minute a
day to focus on how you will achieve a
goal just 1 minute day can you take one
minute a day to focus on your health
yeah can you take one day to retrain
your brain yeah can I take one day
you know or one action a day right and
you start off with something you know
and reduce it down to just a minute or
two minutes or one behavior if you can
get that behavior to be a habit it's
easy to stack right of course it's just
like the foundation of a building once
you have the foundation if you build it
right you stack yeah and so every good
discipline effects another and every bad
discipline affects others now I've got a
special bonus tip with Tom bill you on
how to get out of the matrix that I
think you can enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watched a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what is the negative belief that you
need to eliminate from your thinking
number two what steps are you gonna take
starting today to start to eliminate it
and number three
who's gonna help hold you accountable to
make sure you follow through and if
you're still here watching this video
you made it this far you commit you're
committing you're promising and taking
action after watching this video I want
to celebrate you give me a hashtag
believe that in the comments as well now
the process of taking myself from
scrounging my couch cushions to find
enough change to put gas in my car to
building a billion-dollar business was
all about building a set of beliefs now
I believe that the matrix has us all I
don't actually think we live in a
simulation but I think the movie The
Matrix is the perfect metaphor for the
human experience we have all pulled a
web of lies over our own eyes and the
web of lies is what you tell yourself
about what's possible for you and for
the world and once you get that web of
lies over your eyes you simply see it as
reality and you don't understand that
each one of those fundamental beliefs is
alterable but you could choose to
believe something else in fact you don't
even realize that they are beliefs
Einstein as a quote it's one of the most
important quotes in my life the most
important question any man must decide
for himself is whether or not he lives
in a friendly or hostile universe now
what I love about that quote so it's
hiding in it is that it's a decision you
get to choose whether you're living in a
friendly or a hostile universe there's
no objective reality it just is what it
is you're gonna get what you see you're
gonna get what you focus on and you see
what you focus on
if you want to know the five Monty
routines that are critical for success
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
you've got to train yourself to be the
kind of person that doesn't use the
snooze alarm it's really important to
start every day making a mind